today is Santana's big day or rather
it's her breeders big day jean-claude
Zubrin from SAS grunt in Switzerland her
weigh in before entering the ring is an
impressive 672 kilograms
Santana is a herons cow powerful and
aggressive
[Music]
Santana's mother is won prizes at the
national level twice and she can win -
if she's in good shape on the day Dimpy
targets 40 it also depends on how the
competition performs miracle is one of
the favorites and could be a big threat
to Santana she won a prize here last
year she's a very good cow she's proved
that already
how'd this one get cited the first cows
are already fighting they follow their
instincts to form a hierarchy no cow is
forced to fight but if they choose not
to fight three times or they lose three
times they're eliminated
the cow fight is a traditional spectacle
the strength and willpower that the
animals show during the fights are
simply amazing it's great it's a fight
but out the injuries around a hundred
and twenty cows are going to fight today
finally Santana is called to the big
ring but today she seems to have other
plans she's not up for a fight at all
and to make matters worse is the other
favorite miracle that wants to fight
Santana
oh oh not what Zoo begin was hoping for
he quickly gets his cow out of the arena
Santana's well-being is his top priority
but he still deeply disappointed Santana
wasn't in the mood for fighting I could
tell that when I brought her over it's
better to take her out the family stays
to watch the final fights anyway it
hurts a little but that's the life of a
cattle breeder the favorite takes the
title after all there's no prize money
but the new queen is presented with a
beautiful Belle